hallo freunde der sonne ich bin es
wieder mal eure chemikerin des
vertrauens ich hatte ich bin nicht
chemikerin genau denselben datenbestand
ist es jetzt ein running gag willkommen
zu einer neuen folge kosmetik
wissenschaftlich erklärt viele produkte
werden hier nicht nur damit beworben was
sie enthalten sondern auch damit was ihr
nicht enthalten also wenn irgendwo fällt
drauf steht ohne blablabla geht man ja
davon aus dass die abwesenheit von
blablabla was gutes ist beispiel
nagellack entfernt wenn er drauf steht
ohne arzt tun geht man davon aus dass
aceton was schlechtes ist manuell in den
usa für nagellackentferner auch mit 100%
abzutun beworben und da wird man
natürlich eher denken oh 100 prozent nur
der kunststoff angesagt vieles von dem
was auf einer verpackung draufsteht ist
nur marketing woher weiß ich jetzt auf
welche inhaltsstoffe ich wirklich
verzichten sollte wir werden heute
lernen wie man inhaltsstoffe ließ wir
schauen uns heute drei ohne genauer an
also was steckt dahinter wenn auf der
verpackung draufsteht ohne parabene ohne
silikon und ohne aluminium spoiler bei
aluminium gibt es große news über die
bisher noch kaum jemand gesprochen also
produzenten macht es euch gemütlich los
geht's wann dieses video enthält
chemische formeln ich weiß viele freunde
der sonne sind auch freunde chemische
struktur formeln aber falls ihr bei
chemischen formeln so einen leichten bis
mittelschweren brechreiz empfindet wer
with me es lohnt sich ich verspreche iss
starten wir mit parabene sind wie sag
ich das jetzt warte darauf parabene sind
die äste der paradoxie benzoesäure ist
jetzt nicht besonders anschaulich
natürlich das ist benzoesäure das hier
ist die carbonsäuren gruppe
beziehungsweise nur eure gruppe und das
ist hydrox benzoesäure aber gesagt herr
hütt roxy benzoesäure es gibt auch otto
und meter hydrox benzoesäure je nachdem
wo die sich mit roxy gruppe sitzt und
das hier ist ein alkohol zum beispiel
ethanol alkohol plus carbonsäuren -
wasser ergibt erster und schon haben wir
paradoxie benzoesäure esther ak
parallelen komme
das sind jetzt die einfach
juni basics ist ja der grundschule in
der grundschule gibt es kein chemie
konzentration bitte es gibt verschiedene
parabene also je nach alkohol gibt es
verschiedene esther der parallel tropfen
säure die in der kosmetik verwendet
werden nämlich mit paraden ethylen
propylen und gute paraden ihr seht diese
kohlenstoff hätte hier wird immer länger
sabine haben eine antibakterielle und
anti funkel wirkung das heißt sie machen
und bakterien und pilzen das leben
schwer
und weil sie ziemlich einfach und
günstig herzustellen sind werden sie
recht häufig als konservierungsstoffe
eingesetzt lebensmitteln medikamenten
und eben auch in kosmetikartikel zum
beispiel in lotionen shampoos oder auch
lippenstift oder mascara bei
lebensmitteln leuchtet ist
wahrscheinlich einfach um ein essen
länger haltbar machen möchte aber auch
blumig duftende kosmetikartikel die
geöffnet und ungekühlt längere zeit
rumstehen wären ziemlich früh ohne
schimmelschutz die länger diese seiten
kette ist desto stärker ist die
antibakterielle wirkung allerdings nimmt
gleichzeitig die wasserlöslichkeit in
diese richtung ab denn solche
kohlenstoff ketten verstehen sich nicht
gut mit wasser sind guthro wirklich
übersetzt wassermassen und je länger die
kohlenstoff kette desto hydrophobe fette
und öle zum beispiel bestehen
hauptsächlich aus solchen langen
kohlenstoff ketten und die sind
bekanntlich weise gar nicht
wasserlöslich oder mit wasser mischbar
kosmetikartikel bestehen oft zum größten
teil aus wasser also wenn ihr auf die
inhaltsstoffe drauf schaut ist der erste
eintrag meistens aqua also wasser und
die reihenfolge der inhaltsstoffe
richtet sich genauso wie bei
lebensmitteln nach der menge und wasser
ist auch genau das was mikroorganismen
brauchen und wo sie sich vermehren
deswegen haben verschiedene parabene
entsprechende vor nachteile bezüglich
ihrer antibakteriellen stärke und ihrer
wasserlöslichkeit laut verordnung der
europäischen kommission ist die maximale
konzentration 0,4 prozent bei einem
paraden bzw 0,8 prozent bei paraden
gemischen viel ist es also ohnehin nicht
was veranlasst also hersteller und
kunden jetzt ganz auf parabene zu
verzichten ein grund für die abneigung
parabene gelangen über die kosmetik in
den körper ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das
eher überrascht oder eben nicht
manche haben vielleicht generell angst
dass alles was man sich auf die haut
schmidt irgendwie auch in den körper
gelangt andere glauben vielleicht eher
das so lange etwas die schluckt oder
einatmet alle safe ist man kann das so
ganz pauschal nicht sagen also die haut
ist prinzipiell schon eine gute
schutzbarriere aber es gibt stoffe die
trotzdem aufgenommen werden können und
parabene gehören dazu und zwar je länger
diese seiten kette ist desto leichter
wird das paraffin von der haut
aufgenommen aber nur bei etwas in den
körper gelangt heißt es doch nicht
automatisch dass es auch schädlich ist
man kann parabene im urin nachweisen
aber das heißt jetzt auch erstmal nur
dass wir sie wieder ausfallen was ja
auch erstmal gut es gibt aber einen
verdacht der paraden einen schlechten
ruf verleiht nämlich dass die sogenannte
endokrine disruptoren sein könnte das
heißt substanzen die auf schändliche
weise in den hormonhaushalt des körpers
eingreifen der verdacht stützt sich auf
einen plausibel mechanismus nämlich
parabene können an östrogen rezeptoren
binden östrogene gehören zu den
sexualhormonen also wie alle hormone
haben sie viele funktionen zb bei der
knochenbildung oder im stoffwechsel
aber vor allem sind östrogene für die
geschlechtsreife bei mädchen und frauen
zuständig in laborversuchen mit zellen
also in vitro wurde so eine erste
wirkung von kabinen auch tatsächlich
beobachtet und zwar umso stärker je
länger die seitenketten doch in vivo
also in tierversuchen gab es bisher
uneinheitliche ergebnisse und ergebnisse
aus tierversuchen lassen sich ohnehin
nur bedingt auf menschen übertragen und
wie bei vielen potenziell schädlichen
stoffen ist es oft nicht ethisch
vertretbar systematischen studien an
menschen durchzuführen man kann schon
dessen beobachtungsstudien machen die
waren bisher aber so mittel gut beispiel
in dieser studie wurden 264 kinder
beziehungsweise heranwachsende ab einem
alter von neun jahren über mehrere jahre
begleitet man hat unter anderem
beobachtet wann
denn die pubertät einsetzt und wie viele
parallele sie im urin haben dabei zeigte
sich folgender zusammenhang bei mädchen
mit einer höheren konzentration von metp
arabin in urin setzten auch bestimmte
anzeichen der pubertät früher ein
nämlich die erste periode das auftreten
von staaten und das wachstum der brust
heißt das jetzt dass parabene zu einer
früheren pubertät führen
nein es kann auch genau anders rosa
nehme ich das mädchen die früher in die
pubertät kommen früher mehr
kosmetikartikel benutzen und deswegen
auch mehr parabene im urin haben
außerdem betonten die autoren dieser
studie auch dass sie die teilnehmer zwar
über jahre beobachtet haben werden
dessen aber nur zwei dreimal urinproben
genommen haben und wenn parabene jetzt
sehr schnell wieder ausgespült werden
hat das ohnehin nicht große aussagekraft
es gibt ein aktuelles review dass es
dieses jahr also 2020 veröffentlicht
wurde
hier immer nicht angeschaut wie viele
parabene tatsächlich in verschiedenen
produkten enthalten sind wie viel davon
dann auch tatsächlich über die haut in
den körper gelangt und welche
höchstmengen verschiedene studien noch
als harmlos befunden haben unterstrich
kommen die autoren zu dem ergebnis dass
einzelne kosmetikprodukte mit para
bienen der besten kenntnis nach kein
risiko darstellen
aber es nicht ausgeschlossen dass manche
menschen so viele unterschiedliche
parabene haltige produkte benutzen
dass es dadurch doch zu einem
gesundheitsrisiko kommen könnt also
gelangen parabene in den körper werden
sie auch wieder ausgeschieden ja können
sie an den es trug den rezeptor binden
ja richtet das schäden an
in diesen kleinen dingen wahrscheinlich
nichts dazu kommt dass die östrogene
wirkung von papieren in bisherigen
studien deutlich schwächer war als bei
körpereigenen östrogen aber wenn man
sehr oft sehr viel paraden haltige
produkte benutzt ist es nicht
auszuschließen dass irgendwann eine
bedenkliche dosis erreicht werden könnte
unsere funk kollegen von steuerung f
cola und desiree haben in ihrem neuesten
video einen großen parfüm selbst ist
gemacht mit urin proben unter anderem
auch mit einem urin fail
ich wähle ich zu viel verraten schaut am
besten selbst bei vorbei parabene sind
jetzt so ein klassisches beispiel für
eine unbefriedigende datenlage also
natürlich hätte man lieber ein klares ja
oder nein
in die praxis übersetzt heißt das wie so
oft am besten alles in maßen deutlicher
ist die lage allerdings bei silikonen
silikone während kosmetisch viel genutzt
berühmter weise in der kosmetischen
chirurgie und das möglicherweise
zunehmend denn während bis zu den 90ern
ist vor allem brustimplantate waren sind
ja inzwischen auch po implantate sehr
beliebt denn wir wissen alle bei einer
kanada an
unless you got panzer in shampoos oder
haar spielerin werden silikone als
conditioner eingesetzt dh sie verleihen
dem h glanz und geschmeidigkeit und auch
wenn es andere könnte schon es gibt
außer silikon haben sie die kohle meiner
meinung nach mit abstand den besten
conditioning effekt trotzdem wer in
shampoos und spülungen zunehmend damit
beworben silikon frei zu sein
meistens werden sie die ohne dabei unter
dem label chemie gehandelt also ohne
silikone und ohne chemie wird oft im
selben satz genannt
das eigentliche problem mit silikon ist
natürlich nicht dass sie chemisch sind
was korrekter weiß natürlich heißen
müsste dass sie künstlich hergestellt
sind aber etwas künstlich hergestellt
wurde oder auch etwas natürlichen
ursprungs ist sagt nichts darüber aus
welche eigenschaften dieser stoff hat
die eigenschaften eines stoffes
natürlich die künstlich ergeben sich aus
der chemischen struktur silikone sind
police roxanne man kann auch sagen polio
ghana siloxan die vorsilbe poly bedeutet
dass sie die krone polymere sind das
heißt langkettige moleküle das backbone
dieser langen kette besteht aus
abwechselnden silizium und
sauerstoffatom im silizium atom hängen
außerdem noch sogenannte organische
reste also kohlenstoff gruppen daher
auch organo sehr gängig sind zwei
sogenannte methylgruppen das sind uns
euch jetzt sie hat drei gruppen dann
heißt diese silikon poly die
die tür siloxan ein anderer name ist die
mit ikonen zeit auf der innenstadt liste
findet ihr silikone sowohl und den damen
siloxan oder die mit am häufigsten
eingesetzt werden zyklische silikone wie
china größe cyclo tetra siloxan die
penta siloxan und citroen exaflop sahen
die auch mit d4 d5 und die sechs
abgekürzt werden nicht verwechseln mit
homöopathischen potenzen die silizium
sauerstoff bindungen sind relativ
flexibel ist wenn das jetzt die
bindungen sind zwischen sauerstoff
silizium sauerstoff dann ist dieser
bindungs winkel relativ flexibel und war
außerdem können sich diese methylgruppen
freiheit reden und auch entlang der
kette kann sich das molekül in
verschiedene richtungen drehen diese
allgemeine beweglichkeit in der
chemischen struktur sorgt für die
charakteristischen eigenschaften von
silikonen nämlich sie sind weiche
elastische flexible materialien obwohl
sie die kohle schon in den 40ern zum
ersten mal in einer bodylotion verwendet
wurden war ihr einsatz lange beschränkt
weil sie in wasser löslich sind und
normalerweise sind wasserunlösliche
sachen dann wenigstens öl löslich aber
selbst in öl oder in anderen gängigen
organischen lösungsmitteln sind silikone
auch nicht besonders geil löslich also
silikone sind generell ziemlich schlecht
löslich und das ist ein problem wenn man
dann versucht silikone in shampoos
einzumischen
dann wird es einfach nur glücklich oder
setzt sich am boden ab und so kriegt man
das natürlich auch nicht gescheut aufs
haar er sich erfolgreich club media
riskieren will dem sei ihr ein
roggenmehl shampoo empfohlen also was er
dann eben kein shampoo es not tut ist
das stichwort das sagen wir auch mal ein
video gemacht findet ihr hier nirgends
gehört jedenfalls ist ist den meisten
wahrscheinlich gar nicht bewusst aber
die inhaltsstoffe für zb ein shampoo
herzustellen das ist die eine sache
diese in stoffe erfolgreich
zusammenzubringen also zusammenzumischen
ist überhaupt nicht trivial
weil das ganze im zweifelsfall zu fest
zu flüssig zuschauer mich zu wenig
schaurig wird oder weil es nicht stabil
ist die mischung weiß ich was absetzt
und so weiter ein gutes shampoo
zusammenzumischen ist eine kunst ist
wesen schafft es ist buchstäblich eine
spezialisierung der chemie namens
formulierung das heißt silikone sind
zwar unlöslich aber sie sind formuliert
war also durch chemische modifizierung
der silikone und durch den einsatz
bestimmter lösungsmittel und tenside
kann man die silikone innerhalb der
shampoo formulierung stabilisieren wenn
man sich jetzt aber mit dem shampoo die
haare wäscht dann wird er diese perfekt
abgestimmte formulierung durch das
duschwasser verdünnt anders gesagt die
formulierung wird zerstört die silikone
werden also durch die verdünnung von den
stabilisierenden zu setzen getrennt und
machen in der folge das was unlösliche
substanz nur einmal machen
sie setzen sich ab und zwar auf dem haar
und dort bleiben sie auch trotz duschen
war sehr wasser unnötig sind und das ist
eben auch genau der witz also die
silikone bilden auf dem haar an den
dünnen film der jetzt auch besonders
gleichmäßig und glatt ist und das licht
besser reflektiert als das nackte h
deswegen der glanz außerdem sorgt diese
klasse beschichtung auch für den
conditioning effekt also für die bessere
can barkeit und geschmeidigkeit ihr habt
doch bestimmt schon weise mikroskopie
aufnahmen von hagens gesehen die haben
ja so schoben oder haare können
natürlich auch schließlich seien das
ganze wird dann eben versiegelt durch
die silikone gleichzeitig führt das zu
dem eigentlichen problem nämlich weise
die krone so schlecht löslich sind
wirken sie auch nur schlecht wieder los
also natürlich hilft das auch das
physikalische reihen dabei das zeug nach
und nach wieder loszuwerden aber
prinzipiell lassen sich silikone nur
sehr schlecht auswaschen und wenn man
jetzt jeden tag oder bei jeder
haarwäsche silikon haltige produkte
benutzt kommt es zu einem bild ab durch
den bild ab während die haare mit der
zeit schweröl ich fertig schlapp
deswegen ist durchaus sinnvoll ist das
shampoos und spülungen auch ohne sie die
kohle verkauft werden wobei ich
persönlich sagen muss ohne sieg wurde
ich will aber sieg und ich habe ziemlich
dicke asiatische die aber auch relativ
trocken und spröde sind also ich benutze
sehr gerne silikon haltige spülungen
auch wenn ich sie mir halt nicht auf
einen einsatz machen sondern nur so ab
hier rein schmiere
aber ich finde es gut dass silikone das
habe ich werden und wie gesagt ist
die besten kunden wer jetzt aber sehr
feine oder leicht fahrrad sollte
wirklich liebe auf silikone verzichten
was passiert es aber mit den silikonen
nachdem sie den abfluss runtergespült
wurden
naja weil sie halt so schlecht lässig
sind setzt sich fast alles im
klärschlamm also in dem festen abfall
der kläranlagen habe silikonen die jetzt
irgendwie in der umwelt landen sei es in
böden oder halt auf mülldeponien zu
setzen sich unter sauren oder basischen
bedingungen ganz gut davon abgesehen
sind sie relativ ihn ehrt das bedeutet
sie gehen kaum chemische reaktion ein
sind also auch schlecht abbaubar also
auch da gibt es gewissermaßen ein bild
ab es gibt allerdings wenig hinweise
darauf dass sie die kohle
mikroorganismen oder tieren die in der
umwelt damit in berührung kommen schaden
zusammengefasst wer eher feines oder
fettiges haar sollte auf silikone
verzichten
davon abgesehen sind sie eher
unbedenklich musikern aluminium ohne
aluminium sind ja viele deos wobei die
hausse eigentlich sowieso kein aluminium
enthalten also das was wir
umgangssprachlich als deos bezeichnen
umfasst eigentlich zwei verschiedene der
dinge nämlich erstens theodor anziehen
und zweitens antitranspirantien theodor
anziehen helfen nicht gegen schweiz
sorgen nur dafür dass der schweiß nicht
stinkt zwar erstens mit parfüm und
zweitens mit antibakteriellen stoffen
zum beispiel triclosan denn eigentlich
ist nicht der schweiz das problem
schweiß an sich ist geruchlos das
problem sind bakterien die in unseren
achselhöhlen leben und die sich von dem
schweiß bzw von den proteinen in dem
schweiß ernähren und dabei
stoffwechselprodukte erzeugen die
stinken nach schweiß antitranspirantien
hingegen hemmen wirklich das schwitzen
und zwar mit hilfe von aluminium genauer
gesagt aluminiumsalze wie
aluminiumchlorid oder aluminiumhydroxid
loritz wenn diese aluminiumsalze auf
protein in unserer schweiz treffen
bilden sie unlösliche flocken oder
tropfen stopfen die halt unsere schweiz
poren verstopfen
dieses bilden unlösliche ablagerungen
nennt man ausfällen also diagnose fällen
proteine aussagen übrigens gibt es auch
solche natur kristall deos die sehr gute
antitranspirantien sind weil sie zu
einer
aus aluminiumsalzen bestehen das sind
zwar andere aluminiumsalze als die im
deo was aber auch egal ist weil er das
aluminium das problem ist und nicht der
rest des alls es also so viel zu der
logik hinter naturkosmetik ohne chemie
sagt doch ich finde es ja generell eine
sehr unangenehme vorstellung so
verstopfte schweißporen zumal schwitzen
ja auch eine sehr effiziente art der
abkühlung ist und die uns einige tiere
sehr beneiden würden ich meine generös
legen sich in der australischen hitze
die unterarme ab um durch das verdunsten
des speichers abzukühlen die würde uns
auslachen wenn sie wüssten dass wird
freiwillig unsere schweiß poren
verstopfen
wo war ich jetzt aluminium obwohl
aluminium ein sehr häufiges element ist
und wie es deswegen täglich zu uns
nehmen übers essen über trinken ja sogar
in kleinen mengen über die luft die wir
einatmen ist aluminium ab einer gewissen
dosis gesundheitsschädlich sehr hohe
dosen führen zu einer aluminium
vergiftung bei der unter anderem die
knochen oder das gehirn geschädigt
werden können einige erforschen den
verdacht dass auch schon kleinere mengen
an aluminium das risiko für bestimmte
krankheiten erhöhen könnte zum beispiel
krebs oder alzheimer
allerdings gibt es dazu bisher keine
überzeugenden hinweise es ist hier also
ein klassischer fall von die dosis macht
das gift und es gibt den empfohlenen
höchstwert von einem milligramm pro
kilogramm körpergewicht und woche das
bfr also das bundesinstitut für
risikobewertung rät aluminium quellen zu
vermeiden wenn es den geht denn einige
lebensmittel enthalten auch schon so
aluminium zum beispiel einige
getreidesorten miesmuscheln oder tee
ist ja auch erst mal kein problem
solange man nichts anderes macht als den
ganzen tag neidisch zuschauen und dabei
pausenlos tee zu trinken
trotzdem sollte man darauf achten dass
man zum beispiel seien es nicht so lange
in argo schalen warm hält besonders
leicht löst sich aluminium in kontakt
mit salz oder säure
also man sollte jetzt nicht eine zitrone
über alu folie ausdrücken und dann
trinken außerdem sollte man laut bfr
nicht immer messen aufpassen sondern
auch sparsam mit antitranspirantien
umgehen denn gerade so an männer die
werbung wo sich die männer so kreuzweise
den ganzen oberkörper einsprühen dass
das irgendjemand wirklich schreibt die
kommentare jedenfalls in der
stellungnahme vom bfv november 2019 also
ganz aktuell wurde noch dazu geraten
sparsam mit antitranspirantien umzugehen
aber eigentlich war die datenlage zur
aluminium bisher noch nie so richtig
alarmierend aber irgendwie halt auch
nicht so richtig klar dass man halt
immer wieder lesen konnte es wird gerade
noch genauer erforscht stay tuned schon
was euch sagen freunde der sonne das
tune bleiben hat sich gelohnt denn
tatsächlich gab es diesen märz große
news aus der alu forschung so wurde eine
neue stellungnahme basierend auf neuen
studienergebnissen veröffentlicht vom
scc es dem wissenschaftlichen ausschuss
verbrauchersicherheit der eu und ist
diese stellungnahme diesen märz
irgendwie wiesen untergegangen also die
menschen hatten diesen mir jetzt
irgendwie andere prioritäten als neue
antitranspirantien forschung dabei hat
das ergebnis dieser stellungnahme
durchaus aufmerksamkeit verdient denn
der scc es kommt durch die neuen studien
zu dem schluss im vergleich zu aluminium
aufnahme durch die nahrung macht es
einfach keinen unterschied welches die
ich benutze die mengen die durch die
hausse oder kosmetiker tatsächlich
aufgenommen werden haben sich jetzt als
vernachlässigbar herausgestellt dass ist
also ganz anders als das was doch im
november vom bfr veröffentlicht wurde
ich hatte mich ziemlich gewundert als
ende letzten jahres das bundesinstitut
für risikobewertung noch mal groß
gewarnt hat vor einer möglichen gefahr
durch ein
in kosmetika obwohl damals er diese
eu-studie im abschluss war und die
ergebnisse noch nicht vorgelegen haben
das ist hinnerk feld wischt rentrop bei
margareta weise sagt müsste feld genannt
trend ob mein kollege aus dem club der
wissenschaftsjournalisten mit
komplizierten namen sind sie tut es
jetzt in einer ziemlichen zwickmühle
denn wie sich herausgestellt hat haben
seine warnungen teils auf falschen
annahmen beruht und es müsste diese
jetzt irgendwie korrigieren oder
zurückziehen aber was einmal in der welt
ist lässt sich ja leider nicht so leicht
wieder richtig stellen und das ganze hat
natürlich auch zur verunsicherung der
verbraucher noch mal mit mal getragen
merck ist mitgründer des online-magazins
matt walsh und seiner kollegin nicola
recherchiert er zu falsch infos aus dem
gesundheitsbereich in seinen neuesten
artikel stellt nicht nur die neuen
studienergebnisse vor sondern fragt auch
beim bundesinstitut für risikobewertung
nach ob sie jetzt ihre waren
zurücknehmen und bei den herstellern ob
sie jetzt eigentlich weiter mit ohne
aluminium werden wollen wenn ihr gerne
meine schaut wird euch auch mit watch
gefallen ich habe euch den artikel von
hinnerk unten verdingt schaut danach dem
video unbedingt vorbei vor allem wenn
ihr euch jetzt fragt habe ich jetzt die
letzten jahre umsonst ado freistil
benutzt und wie ein schwein geschwitzt
wobei schweine in wirklichkeit auch kaum
stützen können wo wir wieder beim thema
wären ich habe übrigens immer zwei duos
zuhause 1 mit und als ohne aluminium
also ich schwitze hat nicht so viel und
ich finde an die transparenz ihren eher
unangenehmer das macht meine achse
irgendwie so trocken dass es schon fast
juckt ich benutzte ja ich wirklich nur
aus optischen gründen wenn die
schweißflecken unbedingt vermeiden
möchte wie heute zum beispiel ja
ansonsten nutze ich nur normale die
hausse aber ich wäre ohnehin mal dafür
dass wir schweiß legen endlich mal
gesellschaftlich akzeptieren solange wir
alle dafür sorgen dass wir uns
gegenseitig anstecken das doch die
hauptsache oder müssen wir uns wirklich
die schweißporen verstopfen denkt an die
kängurus ansonsten schreibt gerne in die
kommentare über welche kosmetikartikel
oder inhaltsstoffe ich in zukunft was
machen soll ich werde euch hier noch ein
video über mizellen wasser indem lernt
ihr hier das perfekte reinigungsprodukte
findet nicht anhand der claims die auf
der verpackung stehen sondern anhand der
inhalte
liste und ich werde euch auch noch mal
das video von steuerung f die übrigens
den grimme online award gewonnen haben
herzlichen glückwunsch und vergesst wie
gesagt nicht bei hintergrund mit watch
vorbeizuschauen und wenn ihr das alles
gemacht habt ist der song hat auch schon
rum und ihr seid viel schlauer wir sehen
uns in zwei wochen bis dahin bleibt
sicher